hi i did uh
say on the films that uh
if anybody want to ask questions i'll
try and answer them
and i've been asked one that's a bit
awkward
and i've been thinking about it so
i hope i don't know i'll upset too many
iwama people here while we're trained
people
but i want to give a balanced
view of what i think perhaps not of all
the stars i would never live long enough
to cover them but
the style known as
iwoman style that was taught by
cytosensing more than who ishiba scentsy
because
uh oh sensei sorry
because we don't really know what i
taught you know we
see very few films of him
and he's mainly doing coke in aggie or
irinagi
very very few techniques over the
23 24 years of cytosensei being
not only his student but also his carer
means that he was with him night and day
whenever he
sense he wanted him
when i was in staying in iwama
my friend uh just a short story really
first
my friend said we were sleeping in the
dojo and
then at the side of the main dojo
there's a small kitchen
it's called chisekado and it means the
small kitchen
and we would sleep there in the
afternoons
and keep our clothes and geese and bags
there
and in the evenings you would sleep in
the main dojo whenever we'd gone you'd
roll your beds out and sleep there for
the night
anyhow in the chisai shaka doe
we would sleep in the afternoon and a
friend of mine who
i went to walmart with
who's always seems to be in a habit of
perhaps not doing the wrong things but
not doing the right things
and making life very funny for those
around him and a wonderful friend
he was while still is
anyhow i try not to mention names even
though sometimes they jump out
this small doorbell
was in this room
just a very small square
with a real button but
in england anya we see on front doors
so unbeknown to me
he decides to press this doorbell
no sound nothing keeps pressing it
and then turns and says
i want what this doorbell is for
well very shortly after we soon found
out
one of the japanese uchidashi has come
running from such a sense's house
saying what do you think you're doing
pressing that bell
that bell was only pressed by osensei
and it was to call cytosensi
so the the funny thing was this led to
a story being told by cytoscopy
to us and he said don't press that bell
because that
i've left the bell there because it
the place has to be exactly as though
sensei left it
and he wanted to keep everything in
place
and what we found was a such a sense he
said
because it was just the bell at the
other end of the button
and it would ring and it would ring
inside of sense's house
and cytosensei and his wife both were
carers
so cytosexy would run across as fast as
he could
try scentsy and say hey sensei what
would you what do you need me for
and i sense he would often say i don't
want you
i want your wife. so
psychosensity would have to run back and
tell his wife that she was needed
and i still find that funny because
a bell doesn't speak and yet
it can have a very strange story to it
i wonder how many kilometers or miles
cycle says he run over the 24 years
of caring for them
and being his student at the same time
asensie as i'm sure you'll know gave
cytosensei a piece of land to build
their small house like a bungalow we
call it in the uk
and said build your house there and for
your services
that's what you can have and i didn't
realize until
this bell was pressed that that was a
communication that they had between them
so back to the subject the subject was i
was asked
is in my opinion the lineage
safe of the obama style aikido
with hitahira
i haven't looked into why he to hero
changed his name to hitahira
but he done so
he also has given his son one of his
son's name
moliere
and money is a name that's given
um i think was religious leader gavitro
scentsy i sense he gave his name to
cytosensei
moliere cetozensi
so perhaps it's fitting
that it here gives it to his son
this i have no idea i question it
i have no idea why he would be
able to give it perhaps you
learn that people can tell me if it's a
name that can be passed on
easily
so is the lineage safe
of iwama style aikido
with hitahera the simple answer is
yes and no
in my opinion why
yes first is because
he's very strong in teaching the weapons
and the thing that denotes iwama
aikido from will say
flying stars i often mention the word
hombu dojo
where the obama weapons have not been
kept
and they're not trained so
he's keeping the lineage very strong in
the weapons
but he's changed a lot of the weapons
from his father's and his father
made created all these weapons sense he
didn't
teach i since he taught the
thirty-one carter
and sight of since he told us that he
asked him
to put the anti-carter to it
since he asked me when i when i was
ordered my fifth down in iwama
he said tony please develop
ken and joe so that the obama weapons
are not lost in the world
and i gave him my word i would do so
and i made some cannon i made some joe
kimmy joe's i made four of them
created them completely myself but i
created them from kumitachi's
kimijos and i took all the parts that i
found
difficult in the kumita in the
variations mainly
and i took the parts from the joe
that i found also very difficult there's
always parts when you're doing
carters or partner practice
kumi there's always parts
don't matter how high level you are that
don't quite fit
so i made these for kimmy joe
to make them fit to make sense of them
because i'd given in my word
that i would carry it on developing them
i suddenly realized and dropped this
and i don't teach them anymore
reason is the same situa
he is modified and changed and some
for the better but what's happening now
is i'm very disillusioned with iwama
aikido because i don't really know
what it is anymore i'm
happy with my foundation i'm 100
a follower of cytosensei and he's the
aikido he taught me
but the weapons are made given to us
to improve thai jitsu
since he would say when doing weapons
think of taijitsu
when doing taijitsu think of weapons
how can one do this if your mind's full
of um
i've got to learn all these weapons
and then next year they'll be modified
and changed oh
i've got to learn this way your mind is
so full of
the technical then you don't actually
find the spiritual flow
of what it should do it should the keema
soon be no touch
for those of you know this is done
straight after the ken partner practices
so you do the saburi's ken seven kenza
berries
that's like a warm up then you get
serious and you say okay i've got to now
tie together with another person
so we then do the
keema souvenir attach it's wonderful i
love it
i never tire of it it
brings your zan chin shut up it makes
your engine sharp
you're blending it has everything that i
could ever want
for in my aikido
the attaches i also love the kumijos
i love
but there's too many of them there's far
far too many of them and hitahiro
he's done things in his aikido
that i wasn't taught by his father
yes it does sound like a criticism
but the flowing stars on a coat of gosh
they go back to back once taking the
wrist
or the hand cytosensor used to go
in a diagonal move to the side
look at the films don't take my word for
it
i go to the side i know that most of the
obama people
that suther city taught go to the side
why did he decide to go round the back
perhaps so sense he did
i know that the flying styles do but to
me
it's a great deal of movement
unnecessarily
another thing cytosensei taught us was
those senses aikido is very economical
you do as little as possible to execute
the move you need the flowing stars
they tend to do big movements very
beautiful
but you could never ever do this in a
real situation
in a real situation you might do a tenth
of the whole technique i remember once
somebody went to punch me i was in
czechoslovakia of all places
in a bar somebody went to punch me
because i
he thought that i was speaking
rudely against the black person i didn't
even know the black person was there at
the bar
he was quite drunk he kept started
poking me said apologize to him i said
who who he pointed to the black person
i said i don't need to apologize because
i don't even know the person
the next thing the punch came
towards my face all i remember is doing
a quick
catch tweak the punch before it hit me
the nerve in the west here
made him pass out
he was a very lucky man because in
czechoslovakia at that time there was
lots of prostitutes in the hotels
and five prostitutes
almost picked him up rather than dragged
him to the left
and took him back to his room
the next morning he come down
with his arm in a bandage
and recognized me what's strange he
couldn't have been that drunk
and he came up to me he said i'd like to
worry i said i don't want any trouble i
don't want any trouble
he said no no i don't mean that he said
i just want to know
what the hell did you do to me
so you see and that was a niccio
but it was not the nikki i would choose
it was a
tenth perhaps even a minuscule
amount of a tenth even but it worked
so cytoscencey to me is correct by
minimalizing what you have to do
so to me the weapons have become
far too vast heater here is extended on
them
so i don't believe his lineage is
like his father it's watered down
it's very difficult for me to be honest
with you
well i'm trying to be and also
not be disrespectful
but sometimes i have children of my own
and we go on fine sometimes children
clash with their parents
they rebel they'll do anything
to go the opposite way
to their parents
and that's as far as i'd like to go with
that
but keeping iwama aikido
strong he's got beautiful dojo
and he's got a good following
most of the following that i see of
young people or new people some
of the psychosenses
older people like myself students
did give their allegiance to him
and follow him but the majority didn't
and and i don't know what their story is
but mine is quite simple
i think he's a great master and i
was hoping that he was going to become
even greater than his father
in aikido but
when you find a master who is that
good that outstanding he understood the
western mind
he understood the japanese mind
he gave the world far more than most
people that will ever
know why would i need another master in
my life
so when he passed away i apologize to
he'd hear her
as it was he's a hero at the time and i
said to him i would carry his name
and organization in the uk until we
found another
that we did but i wouldn't be able to
follow him
because i was getting older and i'd
still got a great deal in me
that i had got to work through from his
father
so i couldn't follow him
so the answer to the question is
to me he's changed a great deal
of things that i was told not to do
by his father you'll notice
that when they step with the ken cuts
they make big steps they lift the foot
quite high this
is completely wrong inside the senses
eyes because satoshi said
please keep your foot as close to the
ground
and don't allow the enemy to see you
move
it because as soon as the enemy sees
that you're moving your foot
they know that you're going to come and
attack them
and they could count or prepare their
self
so you see this is a complete opposite
that the son is doing to what the father
taught
there will be justifications why it's
done
but i work on logic i work on
what does tony think what does my brain
tell me
is a good thing or bad to me keeping
your foot close to the ground
is much better than lifting it
in the early days it was so exaggerated
it was like kick-starting an old
motorbike
it was like a jumping stamp
we have to be careful because
criticizing stars
we can all do and
i hope that iwama aikido
is safe in his hands
i don't know who it's safe in whose
hands anymore
but i think if we could just learn from
each other
and remember above all it was a martial
art intended
the spiritual side the love
the harmony this is all to be
put into this melting pot and if you end
up
being a good spiritual person but with a
very very
strong martial side
a martial attitude
then you will use the techniques when
it's
required to be used but until that time
you will be a kind person and you would
develop yourself
and your art and learn from everybody
thank you these
films will be continued but not so much
on facebook
so if you wish to subscribe to my
youtube channel
please do so and send comments or
likes or dislikes whenever you wish
thank you